saraghina 16 ans elle est lycéenne et
lors du premier confinement elle décide
de créer virtual classe la classe
virtuelle c'est tout simplement en fait
une plateforme je dirai où on a mis en
lien des professeurs bénévoles qui sont
généralement des étudiants qui aspirent
à devenir professeurs et des élèves de
tous niveaux quand je dit au niveau
c'est soit des personnes en difficulté
ou des personnes qui souhaitent se
perfectionner et c'est un vrai succès
aujourd'hui 15 étudiants du supérieur
sont professeurs bénévoles et une
centaine d'élèves en première année de
terminale profite de ses cours en
visioconférence généralement ils
viennent de france du coup il arrive
qu'on en ait qui viennent de l'étranger
qu'ils en programmes français les jeunes
doivent simplement remplir un formulaire
d'inscription disponible sur le site
sarah elle même élève de 1ère
participent aux cours et consacrent une
grande partie de son temps libre à la
gestion de cette plateforme elle combine
cette activité avec son planning de
lycéennes déjà bien chargé non je trouve
que c'est pas si compliqué que ça faut
juste trouver une organisation là en ce
moment j'ai travaillé plus souvent parce
qu'on fêtait les seront du bac de
français qui viennent ce samedi pour le
moment les cours sont uniquement adressé
aux étudiants en première année de
terminale mais sarah souhaite ouvrir la
plateforme à d'autres niveaux dans les
années à venir